so you have your own personal fridge as
well outside well there's no room inside
yeah okay what's that over there
yeah this is where we store our produce
this is for the restaurant
yes seriously look at last
Oh if I can show you the receipts that
we buy but I'm not just the receipts
fresh every week where we season but you
want to serve it Karen look it's
disintegrating away more fridges down
there Marty how man how old are these
freezers three years old you know when
was last time as defrosted I don't know
bloody now all this stuff stayed outside
yeah Jesus Oh a fridge so that's more
like a fridge
so it's a fridge but it's more bread in
here yeah
this is how much we need this is running
out of stuff you do not need all this
absolutely possible the egg rolls egg
rolls real just hoarding stuff can be
smoked I don't I tried when I was 17
sausage brats this is insane
you've never smoked cigarettes anything
else
I've graduate from high school in 67 and
that kind of marijuana but I took one
puff and it made me sick and I just
[Music]
all right you know I was hungry but I've
sort of rabid today let's start off with
mac and cheese okay what else the
fiestas chew okay lets our out as well a
trap okay right back okay here's this
ticket okay look that's how we ordered
it so mac and cheese are these yours yes
why Portland open I still know wonderful
I like so mac and cheese thank you ma'am
cheese
that's my continue sense the mac and
cheese why is it also bit on top it
looks like a suit it was in the fridge
and then they microwaved it it's scared
to eat that is the weirdest and the most
plastic looking mac and cheese I've ever
seen in my entire life there's no
seasoning in there than salt
ill please deserves a better mac and
cheese
you said it needs to be put under the
bed now we're off to yes just do css-2
so we have a mexican themes to correct
and when was the Fiesta stew made I can
go a sleaze
hey Jill when was the PSS dumain what's
the date on it
let me check 11 1 ok
[Music]
November first
and today today's the space their
separate yes
so nothing's ever fresh oh never
do you want some hot sauce from though
no okay I'll move on to the next course
I'm gonna be take that away